okay so I know people are still coming
in with us fine we don't mind we'll just
get started now because we've got so
much stuff we want to pack into sixty
minutes you know is we can't win no time
for pleasantries or whatever so I'm
Steve and I'm Ryan I'm the other guy yes
the other guy all right so we work
together we're we're both at Microsoft
on the SP net team and we are to the
people who have mainly responsible for
designing what you see in the blazer
programming model today and Ryan's got
extra special powers when it comes to
compiler stuff so if the stuff you don't
like about it and you know who to blame
and we don't care but you know you can
come and tell us anyway yeah if you
found a bug you can ask us and I'll tell
you whose fault it is if it's Steve's if
it's mine yeah it's probably yes I'll
give you a clue it's yeah
all right so we're gonna get started and
in this talk you're gonna get a bit of a
two for the price of one thing because
we're gonna go through two different
subject matters that we think will be
really interesting to you if you are a
little bit more on the advanced end of
the blazer developer spectrum so I'm
just gonna get started pretty much
straightaway with with that half of the
top that I'm gonna focus on and now and
I want to mention that I haven't seen
yours and you haven't seen mine yes so
if an argument breaks out it is genuine
because this is all gonna be new to me
yeah it may flatly contradict each other
so my part of the talk so imagine that
what okay firstly you know that blazer
is a component or intered framework
right you build components and you
construct your application after out of
that if you're a little bit more
advanced you may also know that part of
the design of this system is to let you
put your components in packages and
reuse them and share them across
projects and to even publish them to
NuGet and make yourself into an
open-source superstar so that's what I
want to focus on now I want to give you
some tips on how you can build a really
nice Razer class library that packages
up Blaser components that you can share
and it might be that you just want to
share them with other teams within your
company it might be that you want to
share them with the public in general or
even if that's not the case it might
just be that you want to make things
really good for your future self so that
when you come to another blazer project
in the future you can make use of stuff
that you made in the past in the most
sort of convenien
we're and you can think how I was a
genius for designing it in that way and
it's so nice to reuse now so the
scenario I want to cover of the example
case that I'll be using for a Razer
class library is to do with building
charts you know graphs and pie charts
and all that kind of stuff and I think
it's a good fit for a Razer class
library because you wouldn't probably
expect the Blazer framework to have
built-in graphing features or hope you
don't but you probably also wouldn't
expect to write that code yourself by
hand you probably think that you're
gonna get some third-party package that
gives you graphing capabilities so
that's what we're gonna do for the next
20 25 minutes or so and the particular
way that I want to approach this is by
showing you how we can wrap up some
functionality that's provided by a
third-party JavaScript library so
there's this thing called Chartist j/s
which is a really nice way of making
graphs and charts but it's for
JavaScript and what if we want to make a
really nice set of Blazer components
that follow all the kind of most
convenient API patterns so that I users
can have a really fun time making some
charts and graphs now some of you have a
question I heard that I heard that web
everson web assembly is like antimatter
for JavaScript that it like eats
JavaScript is that true just what
assembly eat JavaScript yeah yeah well
you can use JavaScript from web assembly
what else do you mean I guess I mean
like there there are obviously lots of
like JavaScript components that are out
there that are still useful oh yeah yeah
so like all that sounds like all that's
needed is somebody has to make a blazer
wrapper for that JavaScript component us
and then people can use it without even
knowing you know how its implemented
yeah that's absolutely true
yeah so if we give some nice dotnet API
wrappers to whatever kind of underlying
functionality we want to use then you
can consume that very nicely as a.net
developer and he didn't really need to
know okay how the underlying
implementation worked so how can we do
it well I'm gonna give you eight steps
to success and we will start with a very
basic one which is just how to create
and run arrays a class library in the
first place so over in my IDE here you
can see that I haven't really got
started yet I've got this empty solution
with just this folder you know
I want to add a razor class library you
may have done this yourself but if you
haven't you can do it through the visual
studio project creation dialog or you
can do it on the command line that's a
way of doing that there but I mean vs so
I'm going to start searching for razor
and we get razor class library and we'll
go on from there I'm gonna put it in a
particular place and I'll call it blazer
chart East like that because that's the
thing that I'm doing and then when I
have them create there's one option that
I want to point out to you yeah there's
a bunch of options but the one that I
think is the least obvious what it even
means is this one support pages and
views so what that means is what we're
talking about when we say pages of use
here our MVC views and razor pages so
those are not laser technology these are
a different type of razor class library
and that's not the one that we want
because we want to build something that
works in all Blaser environments
including on web assembly so we don't
want to tie it to razor pages or MVC
views so we're gonna leave that box
unchecked that's just the one tip that
you need to know okay so we create our
razor class library and then we'll have
a look and see what is in that and what
we do find in there is a bit of example
stuff so we've got a razor component and
we've got some static files as well
because razor class libraries can
contain components as well as static
assets that you will use from those
components okay now before we do
anything useful with this we need to
have some way of running it and I can't
run array as a class library on its own
it's just like a dotnet class library we
need to have some kind of application
that it runs inside and so what I
usually like to do when I create a razor
purse library is to create a set of
sample projects that show how it can be
used now do we want to use a blazer
webassembly sample project or a blazer
server one well if we are being
ambitious and we want to make the best
possible cost library we want it to work
in all environments so how about we do
both so I'm going to add a couple of
sample projects right now and in this
talk I'm not really going to have time
to type out everything by hand so I'm
going to use git to jump backwards and
forwards to different points in the
history of my project so we can
accelerate our progress a little bit so
now you'll see that I have got this
samples directory
alongside my source files where I've got
two different actual runnable projects
webassembly and a server one now I'm
just going to start of this web assembly
one first before I tell you how this
stuff is set up so I'll start that going
in my browser right now and when that
comes up you should see it's pretty
familiar it's the typical sort of file
new project blazer thing
what have I changed about well I've
removed a couple of the pages because I
don't really need them I just want to
render one component and I've also got
this little bit of a text up here saying
what environment I'm running in and the
way that works if we go to our where as
that's probably in is it nav menu it is
okay so here's the implementation for
that I'm using this runtime information
API to check where we're running and
displaying either web assembly or server
okay now I've also got a server project
and if I start that up you'll see what
comes out of there should also be very
familiar to you because when that
appears you'll see it's exactly the same
as what we had before except this time
it says M server so to save myself a
little bit of time I don't want to have
to keep copy and pasting code between
these two samples I've actually
referenced the web assembly sample from
the server sample maybe you didn't know
you could do that but you can and then
inside my host page on the server here
the actual root component that my server
page is rendering is the same app that's
coming from the web assembly sample so
I'm treating my web assembly sample as
if itself was a class library and I
could just reference one of my
applications from another it just means
these two applications stay in sync with
each other and I don't have to duplicate
any code okay but what I actually want
to do is use some of the components from
my Blaser Chartist project so I'm going
to go to this index page and I'm going
to get rid of that and I'll try putting
in a blazer Chartist component what okay
and that is what has just come out of my
project template okay so let's start
that going and we'll see what that
renders well by default it renders this
little bit of text which is not super
interesting if you're wondering where
that comes from well that comes out of
our component one RAZR file so that's
doing exactly what you might expect with
the exception that you'll see we've also
got this CSS
class so what is that CSS class well
that is wired up to this entry in our
style CSS file so you see we've got a
particular border and a background image
and stuff so you might be wondering well
why is that unstyled then why didn't the
CSS stuff apply to it and the answer is
because I didn't reference this
style.css file yet so if I'm a consumer
of this razor class library I need to
choose which of the static assets in it
I want to consume and where in my page
they should appear so I'm adding that
reference with this particular URL
format now and if you're wondering why
the framework doesn't that ad doesn't
add that for you automatically that is
exactly your question okay so the reason
we did used to do that by the way we
used to add the references automatically
but we found it wasn't practical in the
real world because you need often to let
your user choose which of the static
assets they want to use and choose which
order those references should go in and
the framework can't know that sort of
thing so if you're the class library
author you're going to have to choose
for yourself and document what
references people should add so now
anyway you can see I've added that
reference and my styling shows up cool
all right so that's the very very basics
now how are we going to bring in this
third-party JavaScript stuff that we
want to use well I've already done it so
let's jump forward and I'll show you how
that could be achieved and now in my
project you'll see I've got these files
Chartist min dot CSS charter Stockman
das and I got those by literally just
downloading them from the Chartists
project website and putting them into my
project and that it's not really the
best way to do this because now we have
to deal with figuring out the versioning
manually and updating manually and stuff
and I'll show you a better way we can
approach this later but we're just
getting started and I've also got
displays of chartres J s where I'm going
to write my own code I've also got chart
raiser and you can see in there what I'm
doing is just rendering it a bit of
fixed markup which are deleting and I'm
also using a blazer feature to capture a
reference to that div so that I can
start passing references to that into
JavaScript okay so I want to use that
now to actually render a chart at the
moment it just displays this this little
message there that says tell charters to
draw a chart so
how do we make it draw a chart well we
probably will go to the website for
charters J s and see what the API looks
like and they're going to explain it to
us in terms of JavaScript and they will
tell us that the thing you need to do to
render a chart is something like this so
you'll new a an instance of Chartist
line and pass an element to it and also
pass a bunch of data that you want it to
render ok so as you can see it's just
hard coded stuff right now but let's see
can we actually call that in the first
place how do we call this create chart
JavaScript function and pass an element
to it from our raiser component well we
can do so using a pattern that you see a
lot in Blazer applications which is that
we use ref to capture a reference to the
element and then inside the on after
render lifecycle method if this is the
first time we've rendered then we can
use JavaScript Interop to call this
method and we can literally just pass
the element directly from blazer into
JavaScript so if you're wondering why
that should be on after render and not
say uninitialized async the reason
mainly is because we're trying to use
this element and that element doesn't
even exist until we've rendered is
something that gets produced by the
rendering process so we can't use it
until we've rendered therefore we're
going to put this into on after render
there's another reason as well that I'll
get to later on okay so assuming that
stuff works now can we do does our
JavaScript code get run and do we
actually render some charts inside the
browser let's see the answer is yes we
are now successfully rendering a little
graph which is cool okay
so we've successfully brought in some
third-party JavaScript and we've invoked
it but so far we don't really have any
proper API there's no way for our
package user to specify what data is
they want to render how can they give us
their own chart data well let me show
you so I'm going to define a few extra
c-sharp class files to do this and I'll
show them to you right now so you'll see
I've now about this data directory here
with a bunch of c-sharp files inside it
for example I've got chart type which is
any num I've got these two and I could
add support for other things if later if
I wanted I've also got chart data and
chart data is you define a set of labels
which
the horizontal x-axis labels and we can
also define a set of series that we want
to plot and each series is something
that's got a name and some data okay
now I've also added on to my chart
component some parameters so you can now
pass what type of chart you want it to
render and you can also pass an instance
of chart data and then when we first
create the chart I'm passing the type
into JavaScript and also every single
time this thing renders which includes
every time the data on it changes we're
also going to call this JavaScript
method update chart and pass that data
and the implementation on the JavaScript
side looks like this you can see the
code later I published it to get over
I'll tell you about that and if you look
inside the update chart you'll see it's
is taking that data and it's passing it
through okay so how do we actually use
this now as a consumer well I'm going to
go back to my index page and you see I'm
not passing any data just yet but I want
to pass some data so the sample date
arrived got looks like this and as you
can see I'm investigating a certain
conspiracy theory that I'm working on at
the moment which is that maybe the
global oil crisis caused Trump to tweet
more or maybe the route the causality
goes the other way I don't know I
haven't decided what my conspiracy is
yet but I'm gonna look at the graph and
try and figure out what it is okay so I
want to render some charts now using
that data so I can simply pass the data
using these parameters that I've defined
so all being well we should now be able
to plot these two series side-by-side
and compare them so back in the browser
reload and you'll see we've now plotted
these two graphs and we can try and
figure out you know what the theory
about the conspiracy is and you could
argue there's no real correlation but I
don't know I'm I'm still going with my
conspiracy theory on that one I'm gonna
punch up some of my examples ok had some
Boris jokes to them okay yeah that
sounds good
just try to mention brakes here as many
times together okay so we've got we've
got a couple of charts that's great good
for us well done but so far we've got a
very very basic API which is not very
good it's not very idiomatic for Razer
if someone is consuming this they will
not feel like they're having a
particularly luxurious experience
because they have to define all this
code down here wouldn't it be nicer if
we could do it in a mol razor-like way
for example we can pass a separate
parameter for the labels like up there
and maybe instead of defining the series
as an object literal we could have a
syntax that looks like this series and
then we could start defining stuff like
that that would be more razer e so how
can we make a better api like that well
first thing is I'm going to go over to
my chart raiser and I'm going to start
adding an extra parameter so I'm gonna
say you can pass some labels but because
this is a nice API I'm going to say it's
optional so I'm going to say if labels
is not equal to null then we're going to
use them and if the labels is not equal
to null then I'm going to write them
onto this data property like that so now
it's optional if you want to pass all
the data as one blob like this you can
and if you want to split it up into
separate parameters you can now I'm just
over writing some data that the user
passed in which is arguably not the
friendliest thing but it's it's a
reasonable approximation to what we want
to do right now so now back over here I
can make sure that I've rebuilt
everything and then hopefully the labels
property will show up in inter sense and
I can start passing my labels in and I'm
going to do the same thing down here as
well and now I don't even have to define
it there at all so that's a slight
improvement next improvement is like I
said I don't want to have to define this
object literal anymore I want to be able
to use declarative razor syntax to
specify the series so how do we do that
well in order for something like this to
work we're going to need to define an
extra component that's actually called
series so let me show you how we could
achieve that and make it interact with
the parent component so I've added a new
class now well firstly you can see this
is what the
the resulting API is going to look like
you can see I don't have that object
literal at the bottom anymore so I think
this is a bit nicer and I'll show you
some advantages of that in a minute but
the actual implementation of it looks
like this so you'll see I've got this
class now called series dot CS and that
actually is a component now normally
when you create a component you do so
using a razor file and that's great that
you could totally do that in this case
as well but arrays a component is just a
class after it's been compiled so if you
want to you can define it with a regular
CS class file just the same the only
difference is if you use a regular CS
file you don't really have any way of
defining the rendered markup because
you're just using C sharp but that's
fine because this is going to be a data
only component it's not going to render
any visible output it only exists to
supply data to its parent so I'm showing
you that we can do that with a CSV file
if we want and the syntax inside there
is more or less the same as before so
we've again able to accept parameters
for the name and the values we can use
the same life cycle methods so when the
parameters get set I'm going to build up
one of these series data objects I'm
also going to receive a reference from
the framework to the owner the parent
component which has being cascaded down
and you can check the implementation
later if you want to see exactly how
that works and then when this thing gets
initialized and added to the UI we're
adding the series to the parent and when
it gets removed from the UI we're also
removing the series from the parent so
as long as I've done everything
correctly I should be able to rebuild
and reload in the browser and everything
will behave like before which it does
but we've now got a nicer API and then
one of the ways in which this is a nicer
API is that the person consuming it can
do stuff in a more programmatic a more
declarative way so previously if I
wanted to make my series toggleable on
and off the user would have to write
lots of code to add and remove stuff
from data structures but if we do it
with razor syntax it can be done
declaratively instead so let's say that
I want to have an ability to toggle
Trump's tweets on and off okay so I'm
going to take that boolean and I'm gonna
say just using normal razor syntax if we
want to show Trump tweets then we'll
have that series there and if not then
we want so it's really easy to use and
to make that
toggleable I'm going to simply wire that
up to a check box that's bound to that
property okay let's check that this
really works so back over here I'm going
to reload and then now you'll see we've
got this check box and as I toggle it
then there's that second day two serials
will go on and off so that's the
advantage of using a nice idiomatic
razor type syntax is that the person
using it can do all kinds of things to
change what's going on at runtime
without needing to know about your
special api's okay another thing that we
can do to make our API is even better
what if I wanted to add some kind of
tooltip to these charts or some extra
CSS styling it's not completely clear
how I could do that as a consumer right
now I could try to do it as follows for
example I could try adding a title
attribute and some CSS styling that's
hard-coded there let's see what happens
if I try and do that right now well if I
do that and I hit reload then what
happens now is we get an unhandled error
has occurred and if we look at the
reason for why there's an error it's
because objects of type chart does not
have a property matching the name title
so by default the person consuming your
component could only supply attributes
that you've declared a way of handling
but if you're a high quality component
author that wants to provide a
first-class experience to your users
maybe you're going to make something
like this work so we can't anticipate
every possible attribute that someone's
going to supply to us but we can handle
them all in some default kind of way so
what I'm going to do is add an extra
parameter to my component which uses
this special API capture and mash values
and that's going to let the framework
build up a dictionary of all the extra
attributes that have been supplied that
we haven't defied defined any handling
for and then I can choose wearing my
rendered markup I want them to go so I'm
going to use this syntax attributes with
the @ symbol too because it's a
directive attribute to add all these
extra attributes to my rendered output
so now that I've done that instead of
the thing that I did before being an
exception we'll see what comes up this
time in fact it works and you'll see
we've got that faint yellow background
and if I put the mouse there you'll see
that our little tooltip actually shows
up
okay so we're treating our users with a
lot of care and allowing them to do
whatever kind of thing they want they
can use that can pass different
combinations of parameters they can use
razor syntax to surpass data
declaratively and they can use arbitrary
attributes in order to you know control
the rendered output quite nicely okay so
we've got a nice API now if we're going
to continue with this sort of goal of
providing the most first-class service
we can then how about we make the
intellisense better as well I'm sure
many of you know that with c-sharp you
can add in line documentation that will
show up in intellisense what what not
everyone seems to know is you can do
that with Razer components too so right
now in the IDE if I'm consuming this
stuff and I hover the mouse of a chart
what does it tell me nothing really it
just says it's a chart have fun with
that and if I hover over labels it just
says so it's an enumerable of string
great there's just no real information
being given to me but the editor
supports XML comments so I could go to
my series class right now
and I could use this triple slash syntax
like that and then I could fill in a bit
of summary text and you can see we can
have these strongly typed references in
the documentation from one class to
another but it's not just CS files I can
also do this from a razor file as well
for example let's say I want to add some
information about this this labels
parameter so I'm going to drop in some
text for that you know it's the x-axis
category labels okay so now I've done
that if I go back over here and we try
doing this stuff again I'll hover of a
series and you'll say now it's got that
information that I just added with the
nice names first reference and if I
hover over labels we'll get this message
that we've added so it's a very small
and simple thing that you can do but it
hopefully gives a better experience to
people consuming your library okay well
okay let's think about compatibility a
little bit so far I've been running
exclusively on blazer webassembly but
does this stuff actually work if we're
running on the server even though we're
doing JavaScript Interop and what do I
even mean by it compatibility
with pre-rendering well let me explain
that to you well firstly let's check
does this work if we run on the server
so remember that we've got this server
sample I'm just going to get that to run
now and you remember I've made I've
wired it up to the web assembly sample
so that it always renders the exact same
output so if I start that up now you'll
see we're running on the server now but
we have the same behavior as before the
same toggling the same styling the same
tooltips and everything and we can see
an easily test that our component works
equally well on the server and if you're
wondering what it takes to make a
component that works perfectly on the
server - there's pretty much just one
rule that you need to follow which is to
do with JavaScript Interop when you're
running on the server or the JavaScript
Interop is taking place over a network
connection and therefore it can only
work if it's asynchronous so if you're
using JavaScript Interop api's make sure
you only use the async ones and that's
quite easy to do because by default
that's the only thing that we actually
let you do for this exact reason there
is a way of not doing it and I'm just
telling you not to override us so you
can see this j/s interface here
it's got invocation can invoke void
async if you use those then you are safe
your code will work on the server as
well there's a way of doing synchronous
interrupt which I will not show you
because I don't want you to do it and if
you do that then it will not work on the
server so just don't what about this
pre-rendering thing what do I mean by
that well when you're running the blazer
application particularly if you're
running on the server but you can do
this with web assembly as well we also
support server-side pre-rendering so the
actual initial markup of all your
components gets resolved on the server
and sends down to the browser now my
application doesn't actually do that
just yet if I look inside my rendered
HTML you'll see at the root here we're
rendering this app element and there's
not really any content inside there
there's this massive comment block which
is how the server and client stuff gets
wired up together but there's no
pre-rendered marker in there if we want
to do server-side pre-rendering it's
pretty easy you can go to the component
tag in your host project and change this
render mode in fact the default render
mode is server pre-rendered but I turned
it off just so that I could demo this
like that if I change it into server
pre-rendered mode then we're going to
get slightly different output from the
web server so if I come over here
and hit reload then now instead of that
comment block or as well as the comment
block we also get all the initial markup
that's rendered from our components
including stuff like this which you'll
recognize is coming from our chart
component and everything works together
at runtime so when I reload we do the
browser initially sees the pre-rendered
HTML and then the interactivity takes
over so what does it take for you to
ensure compatibility with the pre
rendering mode well there's basically
just one rule for that as well which is
also to do with JavaScript Interop
because when you are doing JavaScript
Interop you need to understand that that
does not make any sense during pre
rendering because during pre rendering
there is no browser therefore there is
no JavaScript therefore you can't
interrupt with any JavaScript so if you
want to do jeaious Interop make sure you
put it in the on after render async
method and not inside on in it or on
parameters sir
because all the life cycle methods run
during pre rendering as well except for
this one the on after render ones do not
run during pre rendering therefore
that's a safe place to do JavaScript
interrupt and thankfully that's also the
only useful place to do it in many cases
so as long as you follow that rule that
your class library will be compatible
with all three of these environments
okay right then we're down to our last
couple of tips that I want to give you
now the next one is to do with how we're
dealing with these static resources so
at the moment you will remember that I
put these Chartist files directly inside
my project excuse me which is fine it's
a very basic way of doing things but
we're missing a few features here like
how do we get updates to newer versions
of it also how do we do things like
bundling and minification of our
resources and what if I wanted to write
my Blaser Chartist JS file inside in
typescript rather than JavaScript well
to do that sort of thing we would want
to have something like a web pack and
typescript build process now I know many
of you may be thinking hang on a minute
web pack and typescript the whole reason
I'm using blazer is to avoid those kind
of things right so
that's kind of the point right so if
you're the component class library
author then you're the one who's taking
on the complexity of dealing with things
like a web pack build system so that
your users don't have to you're the hero
in this story so let's be the ones who
add the web pack build system and then
we can get the benefits and our
consumers don't have to even know what's
going on with that so I'm going to jump
ahead again to a web pack build system
and if we look inside the project now
and we dismiss these helpful
notifications then you'll see I don't
have a double double root directory
anymore I've removed it what I've got
inside now is this static assets folder
doesn't have to be called that I've just
made up this name and inside there I've
got some stuff to do with typescript and
web pack for example I've got blazer
Chartist TS and that is a typescript
based version of the same code that you
saw me right before it's a bit longer
because it does all this extra type
checking stuff and it's classes and
things now it's also quite cool because
it's importing the charts Chartist
library from NPM so don't need to have a
separate reference to Chartist anymore I
can just declare what version of
Chartists I want to have inside my
package JSON file and I don't need to
have its actual files inside my project
so that's nice then in order to actually
build this stuff I've added a simple web
pack config if you're familiar with web
pack you'll know this is a fairly
straight forwards one if you're not then
you can just find this code and copy and
paste it later it's pretty
straightforward it's just using the
typescript loader so that it knows how
to read typescript and you will be able
to compile that okay and then finally
I've chosen just to be a bit ambitious
to integrate this with the default
msbuild build system you don't
necessarily have to do that if you want
you can create a web pack in typescript
build system that you just manually
invoke from the command line you can
just go to command prompt and start
running MPM install and web pack build
and things like that on the command
prompt but I wanted to see what it would
look like to really integrate that with
msbuild
so I've made these really awful targets
files that do things like if the package
lock has changed we'll run NPM install
automatically if your target script
sources will rebuild and will also
automatically copy the CSS out of the
Chartists to package
into our project so if I build that now
that you'll see this dub-dub-dub root
directory has now appeared and if we
look in there this is the output we've
copied the CSS out and we've copied this
javascript file out and this is bundling
everything together so I've got my code
in here and I've got all the Chartist
code and so if I just run my project
again now then everything should work
the same as before if I reload that
everything is still working great that's
wonderful and that's coming out of the
build output but you may notice a couple
of things like what about the fact that
this is not minified right now well
that's going to be not optimal in
production well don't worry because we
can set up all the necessary parameters
for that so if I change myself into
really release mode now and I do a build
on this which I will in momentarily then
this time because of all those targets
it will say ah something has changed
therefore I'm going to rerun webpack
which I wouldn't have done otherwise and
we're doing it in production burg now
so you'll see we've now got a minified
version of the output there so we've
automated all these manual steps that we
would normally have to do which is
pretty nice I would say it's an absolute
ordeal trying to figure out this stuff
so I would try and find some example
that that you can copy from if you want
to do this kind of thing and of course
I'll be publishing the code for this
project if you want to check that out
later
ok so that's adding a web pack and
typescript build system we've got a nice
class library now it's got a nice API
we've got a nice build system for it and
finally we're going to want to actually
publish it and share it with the world
you can of course do that manually you
can run dotnet pack on the command line
you can get a new get package and you
can manually go and start uploading that
and you'll get a dog if you want to but
it's a bit of a pain to keep doing that
every time somebody sends you a PR and
you're merging you then have to go
through this process all over again
wouldn't it be nice if you could
automate this process all over if you
could continually deploy every commit as
a new package to new get dog that used
to be really hard to do but it's
actually quite straightforward to do now
so if you've not seen how this sort of
thing looks let me show you there's
probably several ways you can do it you
could do it with github actions or some
other kind of CI system I'm going to do
it with as you'd ever
right now but just just because I'm
familiar with that and because also it's
free if you want to as long as you're
not building your project too many times
which we're not so my my definition for
how that works is this yeah mold file
and it's got a set of steps in it it
says first we're going to choose which
net SDK we want to use we're then going
to run a build to make sure that
everything is happy including all the
samples and then if that passes will run
dotnet pack to produce the actual
package file and assuming that all of
this stuff has succeeded so far and that
we're on the master branch then we are
going to push that up to new gap dog so
when you create one of these config
files like this probably buy a copy and
pasting an example then you can go and
configure that with Azure DevOps so you
create a project on agile devops and you
point it to your source files on github
and it will find the yum or file in
there and it'll say do you want to use
this as the build definition and you say
yes
and once you've done that it will start
watching for all the commits that go
into your project and whenever a commit
occurs it will run that pipeline and
build your stuff so you can see it's
been building every time I've done a
commit on this and if we look inside
there you'll see all the different steps
within my job that I've configured such
as the one that automatically publishes
two new gap dog here you go this is
where it's actually pushing this file to
nuga okay so that being the case if I go
and look at my project page on new get
dog you'll see that we've got all these
different versions of it that have been
automatically deployed to new get every
time I've done a commit and I'm actually
quite scared the people have start to
use this thing already it was not
intentional this is just a demo and it's
very limited functionality bit everybody
go use it yeah send me books I'm going
to disable the issues on get up so you
can't okay
so there you go those are my recommended
eight steps to success as a robe razor
plus library author I hope that's useful
to you if you want to get the code for
this example then you can go to this URL
and obviously you'll find all the stuff
that so with that I'm going to hand over
to Mike link
hmm he's gonna whack you with some other
stuff I'm gonna trip you with this power
hammer here we go
okay great
we're alive here so Steve mentioned
Steve introduced me I'm Ryan I'm you
know of the two of us
maybe the compiler focused person or
this sort of compiler whiz kid or maybe
mad scientist is a more appropriate term
and I wanted to talk to you all about
some compiler stuff mostly because I
think it's cool and I think it's
interesting
so hopefully you do too so about me
developer and architect and asp net core
I've worked on pretty much everything in
asp net core for the last couple years
really had the pleasure to be involved
in the blazer effort and maybe spent
about a year to a year and a half
working on compiler and language
features there you can find my
presentation materials from this and
other talks at that location after this
is done so agenda for today I'm going to
be talking about I'm going to spend 30
seconds you know saying what is a
compiler just in case anybody doesn't
learn that in computer science school
pretty easy to grasp what's special and
unique about the Razr compiler or what
we're doing for blazer and then we're
gonna look at some code and we're gonna
try and put it under the x-ray and
understand it a little bit and see
examine maybe in detail some language
features or what the compilers role law
is or what the steps are you won't need
this information you might you might be
somebody who likes to learn this way you
might be somebody who's like oh man this
is blowing my mind if you're the kind of
person that likes low-level concepts I
think you'll appreciate it and enjoy it
I hope it's fun and it's interesting for
you even if it's not useful but I know I
know some people out there really like
to learn things from first principles so
maybe maybe this is helpful for you I'm
not going to promise that it's not but I
do hope that it's fun and and so in
order to talk about what to do today I'm
gonna date myself pretty severely so you
can choose you can choose your metaphor
for what we're gonna look at this today
I've got I've got two options for you
we're gonna look at the code and try to
see the high-level details that are
buried in in all the code or this is
either gonna be like an old time cartoon
where somebody walks in front of an
x-ray machine or gets electrocuted and
you get to see all their bones and see
all the things inside so simpson's and
matrix may be dating myself a little bit
there but
that's kind of what I hope you're gonna
get out of today so what is a compiler
what does it compiler typically do well
there's a set of steps that a compiler
typically goes through you start with
the source code or the things that you
typed in or libraries that you pull in
the compiler is going to read all that
text and it's going to build an
understanding of that we typically think
about that as a syntax tree or like a
like a sort of tree representation of
the code that you've you've put in most
compilers nowadays are then going to
transform the syntax trees into an
intermediate representation the
intermediate representation is going to
be a little bit closer to what the
compiler outputs and usually is a useful
data form a more useful data form than a
syntax tree for what the compilers job
is and then lastly the compiler produces
some output after running a series of
transformations over the intermediate
representation so that output could be
native code it could be IL it could be
JavaScript in the case of the typescript
compiler or in the case of the Blaser
compiler it could be c-sharp so
introducing the Blaser compiler or the
razor compiler they're kind of one in
the same the job of the razor compiler
is to take your C sharp code your
compiled assemblies that are your
references and your CS HTML or your dot
razor files and it actually produces
c-sharp on the other end we don't
produce dotnet IL directly we produce
like valid c-sharp code that could
actually be edited and compiled by the
vanilla c-sharp compiler so walking
through those steps from the point of
view of the razor compiler we're gonna
read your CS HTML or razor files we're
gonna build those into syntax trees
these syntax trees don't just represent
one language which is kind of spooky
because an HTML document or a CS HTML
document or a razor document has got
that mix of c-sharp and razor so we
actually build syntax trees that contain
multiple languages and sort of embed in
transition between those in razor you
can have c-sharp in HTML in c-sharp in
HTML you can have nesting then we turn
those syntax trees into an intermediate
representation our intermediate
representation in razor and in Blaser
actually is pretty close to a generated
c-sharp code it's pretty close to
c-sharp class so RRR
our represents structural concepts like
classes and parameters and properties
and methods as well as representing
output concepts like markup or
expressions or binding or things like
that so your your razor and blazer level
primitives are expressed in the IR or
represented in the IR as well as a bunch
of C sharp detail stuff like what is the
name of the class that's going to be
generated and then lastly we output
generated c-sharp code so we literally
write c-sharp files to disk and then run
them through the see the normal c-sharp
compiler in order to produce something
that's runnable so some things that make
the razor or blazer compiler kind of
special and kind of unique and kind of
tricky we have to parse and recognize
the structure of all the HTML that
you've pasted in some people may know
that a difference between CS HTML and
razor is that CS hTML is text so when
you have an MVC view or an MVC razor
page or something like that the runtime
is actually treating the HTML as text it
knows very little about the structure of
that HTML and you can do all kinds of
invalid stuff or I guess maybe not
well-formed stuff is a better more
precise term and the compiler and the
runtime are happy with that because they
treat the output as text not as elements
or as a tree whereas in Blaser
everything we create is ultimately a
tree or like an instruction kind of
thing
so in Blaser your HTML actually has to
be correct and well-formed and the
compiler needs to be able to understand
all of the structure of everything that
you type in my friend AJ on the Razr
team quick shout out to him did a
massive amount of work in order to bring
up the HTML parsing support up to
scratch for Blaser when we started the
blazer effort very early on when it was
an experiment Steve's first prototype
just grabbed a an external nougat
library which one was it
yeah we use angle shop thank you sir we
grabbed angle shark which is a great
library yeah Steve grabbed angle Sharpe
off you get it's like I could do this
and we had to retrofit that for the real
compiler but for a long time we sort of
continued in this mode of like while we
we bolted this external HTML parser on
to the compiler
had lucky an adapter layer so that was a
massive amount of work to ship blazer
probably took one engineer about like a
year or two year and a half to bring
that up to scratch in terms of
understanding C sharp and razor
you've got your embedded C sharp
statements in razor we understand like
just enough C sharp to get by we're kind
of close enough for jazz the reason why
we sort of take a minimal approach to
that is if you think about it like C
sharp is changing every release C sharp
is having stuff added every release or
new options or new flavors of syntax we
don't want to try and understand them
all inside raisin if you don't have to
we don't want to try and keep up with
all of the C sharp changes inside of
inside of the C sharp language if there
isn't a need to do it in razor so you
can sort of think about when the parser
is looking at the document we find an @
symbol and we basically try to skip over
the rest of that text without
understanding it deeply because we don't
really need to
we don't really benefit from it it's not
part of the programming model which
helps us there are a whole bunch of
c-sharp constructs that we need to
understand in detail like for each and
if and things like that so if you look
at blazer you like writing blazer code
and you're gonna have an unordered list
you say ul for each or ul app for each
we have to understand the syntax of for
each enough to represent that as like a
for each in the Razr code base in order
to do the correct thing lastly what's
special about the parser is that we
break some rules I did mention that I'm
a mad scientist there's a really
interesting case that we'll look at
today about how we break the rules we
need to know basically all the
components up front in order to do
correct parsing the reason being that
the syntax of attributes is different
depending on whether or not something is
a component or an HTML element so when
we look at your text we need to know is
this a component or is this an element
in order to do the correct thing it's
not really a good language design
practice but hTML is not really a
traditional language either and it's too
useful for us not to do it about the
code generation phase of razor or some
some of the other sorts of things that
we do we we get to know all of your
components and what their types are and
what the parameter types are as inputs
the compiler we need to do that for a
bunch of semantic features in in the
compiler code generation like event
handlers and event callback in those
kinds of things we can't really know how
to do the right thing from a code
generation point of view unless we know
the types of all the components generics
because we support generics and generic
type inference and razor and we will do
an example of that make that very tricky
because there are cases where we can't
know or we have to rely on type
inference or we have to rely on
overloading this also kind of breaks the
rules but it's it's a little bit of a
useful thing for us to not do we'll see
we'll also look at some examples of how
our code generation strategies rely on
overloading because I mentioned that we
know the types of components and their
parameters but we don't get to know the
types of c-sharp expressions so if you
open up a code block and you define a
method and you start typing inside that
method the razor compiler doesn't
actually know anything about the types
inside that method we just get to see
the text which leads to some sort of
leads to some sort of complicated
machinations as a result which which
will maybe bend people's minds a little
bit so with that we're gonna do some
examples that's all the all the slide
where that I've got for you and to do
that I have built the world's worst IDE
so this is this is the world's worst IDE
and it's for rate it's for razor and for
blazer and it kind of only specifically
does razor and blazer and the the
reference the naming the naming here is
a reference to God Bolt org which is a
famous c-sharp and C++ compiler website
that you should check out if you're
interested in native code so if I flip
through I can see that for this document
I've got all of the things that I talked
about I've got the syntax tree I've got
the intermediate representation and I've
got the generated c-sharp and I want to
show a couple things about the syntax
tree trust me that this this banner
component has got has got a message and
it's got a loudness so there's a banner
component that we've defined here about
a sad crying clown I mentioned there'd
be jokes and so let's let's take a look
at what's in the syntax tree for this
and I realize that this is kind of hard
to read but this is this is the code of
the matrix this is the thing that the
people were
the compiler sort of interpret and like
view in the debugger and the thing that
I want to highlight here is like just
how much structure and just how much
detail there is for this so for this for
this image alt a sad crying clown we
don't even have a source element on this
image you can see that we found a markup
element we found a start tag and then we
break up all of this text into
individual little chunks so we've got
the alt we've got the equals we've got
the quotes we've got the values all of
this stuff gets decomposed at the finest
level of detail because we need that to
represent in the structure of what we're
going to generate as output if we flip
over to what the output looks like
there's a bunch of generated stuff to do
with namespaces and file paths and
things like that the output of that is
this we've got this HTML string here and
you can see that we've actually like
taken all that stuff apart and then
we've put it back together into an HTML
string so you wrote you wrote a line of
HTML in your razor file we rip that
apart into like a hundred pieces and
then we put it back together and we
successfully put it back together into a
single line of HTML Bravo that's
brilliant
so what's going on here why would we
bother to do this the reason is we have
two in the compiler take this apart in
enough detail to a make sure it's
correct be look at what are you doing in
here is this all just static text or do
you have some expressions or are any of
these attributes conditional like if you
put a if you put a boolean value in an
attribute that makes that attribute
sometimes appear and sometimes go away
we've got to know all that stuff before
we can turn this into a single markup
string the reason why we would turn it
into a single markup stream is well it's
just more efficient that way so this add
markup content becomes an instruction
that goes to the runtime that says hey
I've got a block a markup and it
contains no dynamic content so when
you're updating the Dom you can either
add or remove this thing as one piece
because it's always one piece and that's
analysis that we do in the compiler
likewise we can look at the invocation
of a component and if I flip back over
to the syntax tree here we can find this
I'll just search for it so you can see
that we've got a we call this a markup
tag helper element so people might be
familiar with tag helpers from
server-side asp net core in the compiler
we represent tag helpers and Razer and
components and Blaser the same way but
there's kind of a mishmash of features
that they share and don't share so we
represent the start tag of this we
represent all the attributes to it so
we've got an attribute here and we've
got the text to satisfying clown that's
being passed to it and those kinds of
things so we basically take it apart and
generate the same kind of structure here
that we talked about on the lines of
breaking the rules which I mentioned one
of the questions that we get asked a lot
about Blaser that I think is a really
interesting question that has a really
deep answer is for this loudness
attribute if we compare those two you
can find that here inside of here we can
see that we've got an attribute value
and it's text which is wrong so I think
this hasn't updated just give me a sec
here I think my IDE is bugging out but
anyway what I wanted you to see is that
we've got a c-sharp expression here
inside of this we've got a c-sharp
expression here inside of this attribute
and this is actually an integer we know
that this is c-sharp code if I wanted to
come in here and instead of 11 I want it
to say 10 plus 1 that would compile and
that would be valid c-sharp code and you
wouldn't see in the output 10 plus 1 you
would see 11 because this is an integer
and anything that you type in here is
c-sharp code if you look at this message
attribute instead I can type in here and
it's just text it's not c-sharp right so
I don't have to have a variable called a
or a variable called sad or any of these
things if I wanted to reference a
variable here I would have to do I would
have to do it like this I have to have
the @ sign to get into c-sharp for this
attribute and I don't have to have the @
sign to get into c-sharp for this
attribute what's going on here the
answer is well we
a special thing for Strings so anytime
you have a component parameter that's a
string that effectively gets special
handling in the compiler and in the in
the tools in the editor in the IDE and
the reason why we do that is because the
alternative would just be terrible so
imagine that you had to put the @ symbol
in and then put in a c-sharp string
every time you wanted to put a string
inside of an attribute to pass to a
component well that would look like this
so you'd end up typing a whole bunch of
like you'd end up typing a whole bunch
of like quote @ paren quote and then
your string and then the reverse on the
way out and that would just be terrible
so this is a case where we actually
break the rules of language design like
you get different syntax inside of this
attribute depending on what the type is
that it's being bound to it's not really
a good language design thing but the
results if we didn't fall if we followed
the rules would actually be really bad
so we do that for you and it's kind of
complicated to make that work but we do
it with love so it's because we value
you likewise I want to look at this one
this this is our this is another another
example this just got some blocks of
like HTML in it and I'm going to flip
over to the intermediate representation
which will probably be the most readable
way to look at this and over here you
can see that we've got a markup block
and we've got a markup element and we've
got HTML content and we've got all this
kind of stuff here going down to this
c-sharp expression for this second
paragraph
so our first paragraph which is an
important announcement about peanut
butter is all one is all one markup
block as we can see or it's - its -
markup blocks as we can see and then our
second paragraph here our second P tag
here is you can see that in the
intermediate representation it's broken
up into like this big series of things
we have an element containing some texts
containing an expression containing more
text and the reason why this is
basically is because of this date I'm
now in here so you can see that putting
some c-sharp into this big complex
markup structure this is that
optimization that I talked about before
where when we can we represent chunks of
more
a static text because it's more optimal
for the runtime it's more optimal for
the generated code but when you put
generated c-sharp in there we have to
represent that as all of its full
structure and generate that out into the
C sharp with all of its full structure
for the runtime to do the correct thing
and these are some of the things that
help Blaser work efficiently when you
update something so like if you just
kept refreshing this page or if you just
kept reloading this page triggered rear
Enders on this component the value of
date time now would keep changing we
wouldn't generate that whole string we
wouldn't turn this entire paragraph into
a string send that entire paragraph down
to the client and then paint that entire
paragraph into the Dom we would
literally just update this inside of the
CM tag and you're seeing that
optimization and work and the difference
between how this first section of text
is represented in in the intermediate
code versus this section of text that
contains some dynamic code if we look at
that in this c-sharp and the generated
c-sharp you can see the same thing that
we've got an add markup content here
with this big block whereas for this
other text we've got this add markup
content here with like a lot more stuff
going on too in order to capture that
dynamic expression let's look at our
next example and I'm actually going to
jump out for these more more significant
examples like this I'm actually going to
jump out to vs code so we can have a
better view of this but I've got a to do
editor here and I've got this on submit
handler so I've got it to a basic to do
list sample with an on submit handler
and I'm passing in this method to that
on submit handler so when this - -
editor submits itself I'm gonna add my
item to my list pretty simple pretty
straightforward stuff we know if you've
done any basic blazer kind of stuff
we're always telling people you know if
you want a simple answer for how to pass
commands and events and things around
the type you're looking for is event
callback event callback has got some
special runtime smarts in it that will
help the system know when to re-render
the right stuff and it also handles a
bunch of different things to do with
acing so let me jump to UVs code where I
have got this text sort of fanned out
for you to look at so here's my index
with my 2d editor and this is my
generated code
so I'm so here's our for each loop we
understood the c-sharp and we were able
to keep going okay here's our for each
loop we're able to understand the
c-sharp and sort of put that out into
the into the output inside of this loop
for each element we're adding an li tag
which is represented by this this is the
opening of the tag we're rendering the
item and then we're closing the element
and then we're going to call to the TD
editor so when you call to another
component in Blazer basically you can
think of that like a function call to
another class we're gonna we're gonna
say okay I want a to do editor to appear
here on the page and then the next set
of things that are gonna happen with
that to do editor is well we're gonna
wire up all the parameters that need to
get passed to it and that's what you're
seeing in the generated code this very
complicated very long set of string here
is how we pass parameters to other
components this is how I live my life
scene so what is going on here can I
help unpack all of this craziness the
answer is that well this API add
attribute is untyped so it's accepts an
object which seems really flexible seems
really good and it is really good
unless you want to get good errors when
you pass the wrong thing because
whatever expression you type inside that
on it submit attribute it's probably
convertible to object right so because
it's probably convertible to object but
we know the type we know that the type
is supposed to be an event callback we
insert calls in the generated code to
this type check method if you were to
look at this type check method it's just
the identity function so it's a method
that take it's a static method that
takes one parameter where we we tell it
basically you only accept a parameter of
this type and then it just immediately
returns that value its entire purpose is
there to make the compiler happy and
make it so that you actually get an
error about passing in the wrong type if
you have done so which I would not
advise the next thing that you'll see is
there is this event callback Factory dot
creates of system string so going back
to our code example here our to new
editor accepts an event callback of
string but
we are passing in a method we're passing
in this on submit' method and it's a
void method that accepts a string so the
signature of that method is basically
action of string right we need a way to
convert an action of string into an
event callback of string and that's what
this event callback factory does the
other trick that event callback factory
does is it takes and takes an argument
as the first argument that is the like
receiver of the event this is basically
the magic that makes blazars event
routing and blazars efficiently
rendering work we're passing some
information into this event callback
that says like who is the owner of this
event or who's the person that's going
to respond to this event so in our case
the index form is the one that wants to
respond to the event and so when we
create an event callback we pass into
this argument so that we're able to sort
of bind that up and say when you
dispatch this event dispatch it to this
component lastly this event callback
factory method is overloaded so in
addition to accepting action of string
it would accept action it would accept
func of string to task and it would
accept func of task and that's the magic
for how all that sort of works in Blaser
so if i came back over to this example
and i said okay this is an async method
now that would just work in Blaser and
event callback factory is the magic of
how that's done it's just overloading so
there's four overloads of that method
and then you're able to pass in those
really flexible signatures and get what
you get whatever you want going through
there let's do one other example how are
we doing on time are we almost out of
time
we yeah we've got one minute left we got
one minute left so I'm gonna do one more
example and I'm gonna go through it as
quickly as I can so I've got a templated
list here and my templated list is a
generic component so my template of
Lists has got a type parameter and it's
a generic component and it is
genericized on the type of item that I'm
passing in so I can pass in a list of
some item and then I can specify how I
want to display each item that's that
render fragment of item content and you
can see that at work in here this kind
of component is nice because you really
get tired of writing this kind of
boilerplate I want to show a list of
something but I
I have a special message if the list is
empty do you want to write that all over
the place or do you want to write a 30
line reusable thing so what does this
look like when we use a template it
lists without specifying the type and
with specifying the type because blazer
has type inference as a feature so let's
take a look at that and this is in the
generated code again so we can see here
that we're calling template list and
this is the example where we're not
specifying the type we're passing in the
items and we're passing in some child's
content where we're basically just going
to render we're basically going to just
pass in that template that gets used in
the body of it to render the item on the
other hand this is not updated let me
give this a kick real quick and see if
it updates sorry about that I think
about down there we go okay you can see
that once type inference gets into play
we generate this little static helper
class here so there's a type inference
class that shows up in your generated
class and the reason is because in
c-sharp there's no way - there's no way
for us to call open component unless we
know what type is going to go into here
in the example where we're relying on
type inference which is this one we
don't know what to pass in there so we
create a static method that then we call
and then inside of that static method
which is a generic method we can call
templated list of T inside of here
whereas in the case where you've
explicitly specified the type of
something we can just do it it's much
more straightforward so Blaser has
generic type inference it's really
powerful it's also really hard to get
right and kind of changes the semantics
of a lot of things or changes the
implementation of a lot of things in a
really dramatic way cool yeah all right
awesome I hope that you your minds are
filled up with excitement about what you
can do with internals of the compiler I
think that's all we've got time for so I
hope that's been fun and useful to you
yeah if we if you got any questions come
and chat to us but otherwise I hope you
enjoy the rest of your day